for weeks Ukraine has been pleading with
its Western allies for tanks it says it
desperately needs to support its
campaign against Russia and now it
appears it's said to receive some of the
most advanced compact vehicles in the
world from the US and Germany sources
have told Al Jazeera the Biden
Administration will approve the delivery
of M1 Abrams Tanks as soon as Wednesday
but they could take months or even years
to actually reach the front lines Russia
says any supply of such tanks would be a
blatant provocation but Ukraine's
President Vladimir zelenski says his
country needs decisions on real
deliveries
there is a lot of talk about tanks about
modern tanks that we need and about the
way this shortfall can be filled a lot
of efforts words promises but it is
important not to lose sight of reality
it is not about five or ten or fifteen
tanks the need is larger machine
discussions must be concluded with
decisions decisions on real
strengthening of our defense against
terrorists Osama bin Javed takes a
closer look at the type of military
hardware that's been promised to Ukraine
and how that could realistically affect
developments on the actual Battlefield
[Music]
this is the leopard 2 a coveted German
battle tank
the 55 to 60 ton stealth War Machine
known for its Firepower mobility and
armor has a 500 kilometer range
the tanks have been in production for 44
years and currently around 2000 are
being used by 13 European armies but
their arrival on Ukrainian battlefields
is still problematic in addition to the
modern leopard 2s considered to be the
most agile in their class other military
equipment has also been promised to
Ukraine that includes the Challenger too
which are coming from the United Kingdom
France has not decided yet but it is
considering sending the Leclerc battle
tanks as well Germany has promised to
send its modern infantry vehicles and on
its path the United States has promised
another military package which includes
the striker combat vehicles
Ukraine is pleading for more advanced
military equipment including a fleet of
300 battle tanks there are pros and cons
of tanks in Modern Warfare
instead of the jet fuel-powered American
tanks the German leopards diesel engines
make their operations easier but
Ukrainian troops will need extensive
training to operate and maintain new
tanks in addition to all the other
military hardware
then there is the challenge of
transporting tanks VIA Rail or on-road
convoys Logistics Fuel expertise and
security to reach the battle arena are
major question marks crucially for
Ukraine how many tanks would it take to
change the Dynamics of territory it's
trying to protect or reclaim
and by the tanks being hardware and use
for 70 years have reached their limits
as practical fighting vehicles
Germany has been reluctant to provide
the tanks to Ukraine because of the
anti-militarism position it adopted
after the second World War
in addition to intra-european challenges
Russia has warned of what it calls an
extremely dangerous escalation if NATO
were to deploy high-tech weapons Russian
diplomats have said Moscow would
retaliate if Ukraine were to use Western
supplied weapons to Target Russia or the
Crimean peninsula mujave altazir
okay well let's go straight to the
Ukrainian Capital Kiev Natasha Butler is
standing by and Natasha why is it taking
so long for the U.S and Germany to reach
a decision on sending tanks
well look Germany's been hesitating for
weeks of whether or not to send its
leopard tanks or allow other countries
that have them to send them also look
Germany has been worried about sending
the wrong signal to Moscow of escalating
the war all of this tied up with
Germany's military past particularly in
World War II now Berlin has also said
for many weeks now that if it was to
send tanks it would want to do so as
part of a wider Coalition particularly
with the United States now we're seeing
the U.S signaling that it could announce
that it is sending some of its Abrams uh
tanks to Ukraine so it does look as if
there is movement that Germany and the
US will be sending these tanks that
Ukraine has said that it needs for so
long some uh the U.S had said in the
past though that it was reluctant to
send some of its Abrams Tanks because it
said they weren't particularly suited to
Ukraine to the territory and also there
were concerns over it needing a jet fuel
but as I said it does seem that some of
this hesitation is being brushed aside
and Natasha as you say there may be
tentative possible movement has there
been any reaction in Ukraine to these
reports that they could soon receive
these tags
uh describe the possibility of these
tanks being sent as a punching fist for
democracy now uh president zielinski in
his nightly address certainly more
cautious he said that Ukraine is still
waiting for decisions waiting for
weighty decisions he said he also said
that look we need to prepare for a
possible new Russian offensive and that
10 or 15 tanks isn't going to cut it
Ukraine wants so many more it has said
for a while now that it needs at least
300 tanks and what most military experts
say is look these tanks aren't going to
be uh the tanks that will be sent
possibly by Germany by the U.S aren't
going to be a game changer by any uh by
any margin but they will at least help
Ukrainian troops because they'll be used
alongside the other heavy Weaponry
that's being sent by Western powers and
they will help bolster Ukrainian forces
as they defend themselves against
ongoing Russian attacks all right
Natasha thanks for clarifying all that
for us Natasha Butler live in Kiev there